ability of oxygen is critical to the way
cancer cells grow and survive we're
truly in a revolutionary time for cancer
care and what dr. Kaelin and his
collaborators discovered is absolutely
transformative this is all about the
importance of understanding the basic
biology of the human body and it's only
from that understanding that we can best
attack cancer so this marriage of basic
science clinical research and patient
cares what is so powerful about what we
do here at dana-farber were all
incredibly proud of dr. Kaelyn and
hopeful for the promise that this means
for patients here and everywhere thank
you I'm bill and I I forgot to actually
put this in but you should know that
bill is the Sidney Farber professor of
medicine at Dana Farber Cancer Institute
and an HMI and at 800 medical school
professor of medicine at Harvard Medical
School and at Brigham and Women's
Hospital and it's lovely to have the
Dean of Harvard Medical School
George Daly and the president of Brigham
and Women's Hospital dr. Betts enable
here to also say a few words
thanks well as as the Dean of Harvard
Medical School as a fellow scientist and
as a hematologist I could not be more
proud of the scientific achievements
that we're celebrating today this
discovery of how oxygen interacts with
tissues is a powerful reminder for how
important critical discoveries and how
the most transformative therapies flow
from the deepest understanding of basic
mechanisms they also underscore the
power of clinical observations to inform
basic discovery so I've known bill for a
number of years now and he is the
consummate physician scientist he's
fiercely
dedicated to rigor and excellence in
both the laboratory and in the clinic
bill Kaelin is the finest that medicine
has to offer and it is a privilege to be
here to offer my congratulations to bill
to Peter and Gregg thank you good
morning I'm Betsy naval president of
Brigham and Women's Hospital and on
behalf of bring a woman's hospital I
want to offer our congratulations to you
bill into your family as well for your
extraordinary accomplishments and
achievements I can say that as proudful
part of the dana-farber bring and
women's cancer center we have great
pride in the scientific research
discovery innovation that occurs here at
the Dana Farber Cancer Institute and
that pride extends to taking those basic
discoveries and translating them to new
advances for patients improve their
lives on a daily basis so bill we're so
proud of your extraordinary
accomplishments as an aside I'm a
cardiovascular scientist so you might
say well whether the cardiovascular
scientists have to do with oxygen and
oxygen sensing well actually a lot the
discoveries made by Bill and his
colleagues have fundamentally defined
how cells in the body sense oxygen and
then how the cells then responds to
either an abundance of oxygen or an
absence of oxygen and you can imagine
that in heart and blood vessels as in a
heart attack there's often an absence of
oxygen and so this oxygen sensing
mechanism is critical for regulating
blood vessel tone and is critical in the
development of a heart attack and the
treatment to a heart attack so bills
work has had broad application across
many fields of medicine heart and
vascular disease pulmonary lung disease
kidney disease and many other organ
systems that we care for individuals who
have those diseases day
and day out at Brigham Women's Hospital
so bills advances our cancer and way
beyond and for that bill we're an
enormous ly grateful and I think bill we
we also just on a very personal note not
only are you the consummate physician
scientist
but you are a wonderful amazing
individual and human being and we can't
think of a more glorious thing happening
to such a wonderful individual and for
that we're very grateful and proud as
well and now I have the pleasure of
introducing the star of the year bill
Kalin I think thank you very much and
thank you for those very kind words and
thank you for being here I hope you're
all having a nice David I'm gonna go
ahead and let me say it's not as nice as
the day I'm having so and on the way
over here I was teasing laurie glimpse
her cuz we just rolled out our new
insignia this week for the dana-farber
and I said way to do a new rollout you
know this really will help with the
branding you know I I will confess like
most scientists and maybe all scientists
if they're being honest I did
occasionally allow myself to dream that
maybe one day this would happen now I
don't think that's necessarily the
healthiest thing to do so I try to
ignore that most most days and try to
completely not think about this and to
try think about my work but when I was
younger my late wife and I would you
know sort of have fun together and talk
about what would happen what would it be
like if you ever won this prize and I
and I say that because I'm accepting
this prize partly on behalf of my late
wife who herself was a faculty member at
the Dana Farber Cancer Institute and
they bring him and Women's Hospital and
she was a pioneering breast surgeon and
she was my best friend and hero and
partner and everything I did and to be
honest there were a couple years after I
that I thought please not a price
because it would just be too bittersweet
and it would be too crushing to receive
such a wonderful recognition without
Carolyn but I'm at a point now where I
like to think she's smiling down and
nodding and saying I told you I told you
this was going to happen and I'm
thrilled to share this with my son Tripp
who's here and my daughter who was
currently a graduate student at Oxford
so we've already faced time this morning
and so I accept this partly on behalf of
my family and my many friends who have
supported me you know I also learned
years ago that I've grown the fastest
when I've been surrounded by people who
were smarter than me and more
knowledgeable than me and had better
judgment than me and so one of the best
decisions I ever made was to come to the
dana-farber for my early training and
more importantly when I had the
opportunity to leave my choice was to
stay because I wanted to be in a place
where the people in the environment
we're gonna make my work better you know
science especially today is not done by
an individual is done by an ecosystem
and I have been aided countless times by
generous collaborators the endless
stream of incredibly talented young
people who have worked in my laboratory
over the years without whom this these
discoveries would not have been possible
I also want to highlight David let me
send who's a professor here at the
dana-farber cancer studio he's my he's
my mentor now you'll notice I didn't say
was my mentor he is my mentor he taught
me how to be a scientist in the 80s and
90s but he's to this day one of the
people I go to when I need sage advice
so I mean countless examples where my
work has been made better been made
possible by the constant interactions
not only within the dana-farber and the
Brigham and Women's Hospital and Harvard
Medical School but this incredible
biomedical ecosystem that's now
developed in Boston so I think there was
a time when you were an athlete you
wanted to be in Sparta and if but they
think if you want to do biomedical
research there aren't too many places
that are only better than Boston and
again I'm just so thrilled to be able to
share this prize with the many many
people who helped me over the years that
have made this recognition
thank you
[Applause]